jetzt hier weiter zu weite strecken
alter schwede man wissen wir doch mit
der lego solo
wir sind so unfassbar loserth skizze und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
wir spielen heute nach einer ewigkeit
mal wieder jump league und wir haben
heute direkt eine richtig saftig
fruchtig vitaminreiche challenge am
start und zwar werde ich heute versuchen
eine runde jump league ohne kisten zu
gewinnen das heißt ich darf in
jump'n'run keiner lag ist luton darum
märz die erste die wird ausgelassen
nicht darf erst wieder anfangen kisten
zumuten wenn ich im deathmatch bin so
alles ktg es soll ihr weil diese tracks
modul gefällt junge leute ich habe lange
lange lange nicht mehr gespielt es sind
locker locker einen monatlich auf einen
monat jetzt keine videos gemacht
wer ganz schön sich etwas mitzunehmen
aber wir probieren es einfach mal ich
habe ehrlich gesagt noch nie so was
ähnliches versucht also ich habe glaube
ich noch nie probiert irgendwie ohne
items irgendwas zu reißen deathmatch ich
glaube es ist ziemlich tricky ich werde
heute natürlich bisschen ein bisschen
runder bisschen unkontrollierte spielen
als sonst da die übung weg ist aber da
mal so so halbwegs kommt man noch voran
und der vorteil daran dass ich jetzt tue
ich keine kisten darf ist dass ich keine
kisten muss soll heißen so eine kiste
blut kostet ja locker also 20 30
sekunden zeit je nachdem ob meine kräfte
oder nicht oder sagen zumindest mal 10
15 sekunden an den 10 15 sekunden und
das sind bei zehn kisten schon 150
sekunden oder zweieinhalb minuten
in der zeit kann ich halt ganz getrost
und entspannt weiterlaufen das heißt ich
sollte auf jeden fall finnischen schon
allein das equipment wegen denn die dia
boots die ich am ende bekommen stamme
nicht aus einer kiste
dementsprechend sind die absoluten geht
und ich dazu benutzen und versprecher
dass wenn man da so runter laufen können
das zu machen ja sehr gut ich rocke
übrigens gerade ein neues hemd dass es
mir heute gekauft haben
ich finde es eigentlich ziemlich nah es
so
ich weiß so der übliche youtube style
ist es ja nicht hemmt zu tragen oder so
da tragen alle rovers heißt es und was
weis ich erwachsen
bis sie ihn keine ahnung da ist ja auch
ganz vorne mit dabei
aber dass ich gesagt so mein stil muss
ich sagen dass ich sehr gerne helfen ich
trage auch gerne mal ein bisschen
entspanntere klamotten habe ich das sehr
gerne händen und dementsprechend war das
ein sehr sehr netter und erfreulicher
kauf für mich obwohl ich normalerweise
wie das habe ich auch immer ein neues
auto gekauft wie du gesagt eigentlich
ziemlich sparsam bin
es sieht gut aus also unsere kisten
verboten strategie führt auf jeden fall
dazu dass wir weiter vorne sind wir sind
jetzt bei 75 der zweite platz ist bei 48
prozent
muss dazu noch sagen dass sich an maxis
pc in das heißt es alles für mich ein
bisschen ungewohnt weil auf meinem pc
zocken im vollbildmodus mit einer
anderen tastatur
max hat jetzt hier nicht im
vollbildmodus sondern nur fenster modus
also das zusammen mit der tatsache dass
ich jetzt im monat kann der blick
gespielt haben sollte als entschuldigung
reichen
hoffentlich aber es sieht eigentlich
noch ganz okay aus das letzte modul im
modul 10 ist machbar ihre module 9 ist
ein bisschen tricky würde ich sagen so
unter den modulen okay der part ist
immer noch ein bisschen ungewohnt ok
passt aber ich muss jetzt einfach nach
gefühl springen zu springen also kann
halt nicht nach auge springen weil alles
im weg total komisch verkorkst ist so
schön aber es ist mir nicht vergönnt und
wir sind beim modul 10
die frage ist jetzt wie spielen wir das
am ende so müssen taktik überlegen fürs
match spielen wir das sehr defensiv also
warten wir quasi darauf dass die leute
runter gehen auf ein leben so dass wir
dann viel abstauben und die deren kisten
vielleicht nutzen könne nicht ab es ist
die einzige taktik die wir
sinnvollerweise machen können weil wir
jetzt einer kommt heute mit chen rüstung
stein schwer tobacco also mit glaube mal
durchschnittlich mehr grip dann haben
wir halt so gar keine chance durch
didier mut haben wir dann noch in
rüstungs punkt mehr die bringen ein halb
leder bringen in halben dann sind bei
viereinhalb rüstungs punkten
das ist immer noch sehr bescheiden
sollten uns vielleicht erst wirklich
erstmal zurückhaltend so das sieht jetzt
eigentlich ganz gut aus das schnell
double lampen okay dann sind wir am ziel
sehr nice namens geschafft wir sind hier
und jetzt beginnt der schwere partie
das regime war der leichte bereit jetzt
beginnt der schwere
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
die jungen wenn jemand mit dir wieder
raus zu sehen die werde mich so zu tode
aber sowas von sicher da kommt er
nämlich schon der kommt einem schon muss
jetzt schnell hoch kommen schnell zum
eisen schwert kommen dass wir zumindest
das schon mal sicher haben oh mein gott
sie durch sie durch sie durch das habe
ich jetzt unter dem titel video
vorgestellt das in eisenstadt auf der
map ist alles okay geben das nicht weil
sie ja habe ich nicht gerade als nuk
disqualifiziert aber wir haben zumindest
das hier und ich will auch nicht lügen
ich habe mir natürlich die map hier bis
in strategisch ausgesucht mit dem eisen
schwert da es sonst einfach glaube ich
zu schwer gewesen wäre aber so sollte es
klappen jungs teams eigentlich ich
glaube es hackt leute es ist fucking
teams verbieten
ihr seid so geistig zurückgeblieben oh
mein gott
ja danke schön das hat jetzt natürlich
noch gefehlt dass ihr euren 85 scheiße
ok
das hat jetzt laut ok ok dem ich mal so
wird jetzt die weiter zweiter täter
schnell dragon alter schwede mann
wir sind auch mit der legeleistung solo
wir sind so unfassbar laut ok legen wir
noch weiter noch regen wir ja dirigent
läuft noch kommen wir noch auf vol live
okay hier ist die kiste die bluten aber
er will es nicht zulassen
dementsprechend muss ich mir jetzt
leider hier ein rein drücken ok und nice
wegkommen und leide afag die kiste ist
auch verschwunden
ok ok um seinem gold wert können sie
vielleicht überraschen
besteht da unser leben zu locker gesehen
kann das doppel gesehen aber bewegt sich
meine kann sie auch richtig gut
unternommen habe ich hab das k
aber ich muss echt bisschen dirty spiele
jetzt gerade ich habe einfach
viereinhalb rüstungs punkte
der mit und davon ist der andere
ok die haben schon natürlich kommen die
fakten zugegeben
und jetzt geht's bergauf jetzt geht's
bergauf so langsam richtig ist equipment
hier gut mäßig sieht's noch bescheiden
aus aber wir können es jetzt erstmal
upgraden von viereinhalb auf 7 rüstungs
punkte und dann kriegen wir wieder full
life also es sieht ganz gut aus das war
du dir glaub ich gerade afk war schnell
daher pro fachleute darunter junge du
bist halt safe gewesen da rufen würde es
dein arsch retten können so wird das
leider nichts
die chancen stehen gut wir haben immer
noch alle drei leben was jetzt gar nicht
mehr so schlecht ist und nach der
gekommen zu überraschen einfach hier im
blog hätten ob es funktioniert oder
nicht das schwert in kombination mit der
rüstung machen auf jeden fall den job
leute wenn ihr wollt dass das vielleicht
auch noch auf einer anderen deathmatch
meppen ausprobieren also nicht auf exakt
wo man diesen kleinen bonus durch das
schwert hat dann schreibt das gerne mal
in die kommentare ab ob ich das völlig
aus wenn wir wissen mehr eingespielt
habe ich glaube es wird fucking schwer
wenn ich ehrlich bin
er selbst die bürger noch einen kleinen
vorteil aber so hundertprozentig ultra
hardcore also quasi nur holz und leder
rüstung im deathmatch wird glaube ich
echt tricky und jetzt holt sie mal hier
noch mal ganz schnell den dude und bei
dir ein bisschen von unten
das tut gut da freut er sich darüber
regiert da bin ich noch mal ja bis 26
okay das war ultra schlecht gemacht
gerade jetzt natürlich kleinen vorteil
aber er hat trotzdem ab ist vielleicht
so lau
okay wir machen was ich möchte die runde
ganz klein klingen gewinnen aber wir
haben halt 0 food das ist ein kleines
problem
die er schreibt xd naja ok fakten wir
das nicht gereicht habe ich bis hin zu
ängstlich gespielt 06 wird auf jeden
fall nicht mehr aber die sache sollten
jetzt eigentlich ganz sicher haben zack
zack zack zack da haben wir es sehr
schön 7 kills ein tod jump face sind so
ein bisschen kritisch würde ich sagen
aber alles zu einem passt das wie gesagt
werden die change nochmal sehen wollt im
quasi ultra hardcore modus ohne waffe
und vielleicht sogar ohne die roots dann
schreibt ist auch in die kommentare
wir sind von nächsten wir wieder haut
rein macht es gut und ja